[Music]
robert downey jr's career may have
reached astronomical heights when he was
cast as tony stark aka iron man in the
very first film of the marvel cinematic
universe but he already had a long
career before that with a ton of ups and
downs so you might be surprised to find
out that he doesn't consider his best
film to be iron man or any of his marvel
blockbuster appearances downey started
out doing roles in 80s comedies like
weird science and then proved his
dramatic acting chops in less than zero
in the 90s downey's film credits were a
bit hit or miss on the one hand he
received an oscar nomination for his
portrayal of charlie chaplin in the
biopic chaplain and his starring role in
the 1995 historical drama restoration
was well received by critics plus he had
a recurring role on the hit tv series
ally mcbeal on the other hand movies
like the sappy rom-com hearts and souls
and the underwhelming thriller in dreams
weren't a big help in moving his career
forward and after a serious drug
addiction derailed his career in the
late 90s and early 2000s downey jr
struggled to find work as few people in
hollywood were willing to take a risk on
him that may be one reason why during a
2020 appearance on the joe rogan
experience podcast downey jr said that
his best film was also the one that had
the most importance to his career kiss
kiss bang bang released in 2005 kiss
kiss bang bang is an action-packed dark
comedy produced by downey's friend joel
silver downey told rogan that it was
quote in some ways the best film i've
ever done it came out and it bombed but
john favreau saw it and he said this guy
could do an action movie that wound up
being my calling card into the marvel
universe john favreau of course directed
and co-starred in iron man in 2008 and
he gave downey jr his next big launch
into stardom and though kiss kiss bang
bang only made 15.7 million dollars
worldwide at the box office it was a big
hit with critics with a certified fresh
score of 86 percent on rotten tomatoes
to go along with an audience score of 87
percent kiss kiss bang bang was also
written and directed by shane black who
downey later brought in to write and
direct iron man 3 after fabro bowed out
of the franchise like downey black was
also in a career slump before kiss kiss
bang bang the writer director had
previously found great success writing
and producing movies like lethal weapon
and the last boy scout but after the
long kiss goodnight bombed at the box
office in 1996 he struggled to find work
in hollywood kiss kiss bang bang was
black's attempt to start over by
branching out from straight action
movies the fact that he himself had
trouble finding people to take a chance
on him may have influenced his decision
to give downey a second chance as well
thankfully for all of us black took the
risk and hired downey to play one of the
main characters though kiss kiss bang
bang didn't do very well at the box
office it did become a cult classic the
quality of the film helped revive both
black and downey's careers and set the
wheels in motion for marvel to also take
a risk on casting downy in the first
iron man film it's hard to believe now
after downey jr's breakout performances
tony stark set the stage for the marvel
cinematic universe to become the biggest
film franchise in history but when he
was first cast in iron man in 2006 there
were many who were skeptical downey jr
could be trusted with the responsibility
his work on kiss kiss bang bang was good
enough to convince marvel to take the
chance though and the rest is history no
wonder downey thinks it's his best film
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]